well audience is bigger than ever for
series 19
19 series of certainly come dancing uh
now watson what is this this is your
third year yes my third year and uh how
often since you've been a judge has your
sister ot won
she won twice
but you know i played she's asking i
mean i'm not saying anything i'm just
asking yes i planned it all you know i
put some oil so jamie slipped and fell
and then she got bulbania and i'm like
yeah yeah no yeah it's funny people kind
of think i have the power of that but
it's not yet
you feel bad criticizing her
no actually i don't look at my sister i
like i look at her partner so i i kind
of not feel so bad yeah but after the
show i'll be like okay
yeah not bad or well done
but uh yeah it i focus more on the
celebrity yeah right yeah it's easier
but i guess it's safe because anton is
now one of the judges he looks so happy
he is he is yeah
he watches him doing the latin dances
and he's like oh thank god
but but this is a thing isn't it that
dancers do judge other dancers it's not
unusual
it's actually the norm this is what
happens after you dance the while then
you're allowed to judge the others and
we're having so much fun with anton i
really i'm really happy he's there
because
yeah it's kind of i feel normal now
[Laughter]
does craig hate you or is that just he's
obsessed with me
he's a stalker i think he's to come out
as me like in a few years because he's
like backstage she speaks to me with
germa like in german but he's always
counting and always saying nine and like
he told me he goes quite often to um
berlin so he really likes germany but uh
yeah he's really obsessed with me like i
have to call security sometime
is that why the perspex is there it's
not over no no that's why i wore those
shoulder pads
stay away from me
[Music]